this episode is brought to you by the
through the web podcast a podcast that i
co-host and talk about all things
science tech and business check it out
in the description below
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
using our legs to do an activity is
something that those of us who are fully
mobile take for granted every day
those who have suffered a full spinal
cord injury have unfortunately had their
lives changed forever being a paraplegic
presents a set of lifelong challenges
that the rest of us never really ponder
but what if there was a way to reverse
this
well a team of scientists have made the
first tentative steps towards a feasible
solution in this episode we'll take a
look
you are watching
tv
this technology is so precise
that immediately after the surgery the
patient can walk and stand
in a clinical trial three men were
recently given the opportunity to walk
again thanks to a new technology
showcased in the journal of nature
medicine the system is a spinal cord
implant that stimulates muscles allowing
them to move again
gregoire cortine a neuroscientist at the
swiss federal institute of technology
and co-leader of the study stated that
this technology was for the most serious
form of spinal cord injury
quote
that means individuals with clinically
complete spinal injury no sensation no
movement in the legs
he also added that the technology could
be used for anyone with a spinal cord
injury that occurred above the lower
ribcage
so
how exactly does this technology work
when the spinal cord is broken the
signals from the brain can't reach the
target muscles so limbs don't move and
no sensation is felt
currently this is usually irreversible
but the thing is the motor neurons below
the injury are still there they're just
inactive
to reactivate the muscle neurons again
the research group used modified
implants originally used for pain
management
in essence it was the repurposing of an
older technology used to block chronic
pain by supplying electrical current to
neurons but this time instead of
blocking the pain the electrical current
would be used to stimulate muscle
neurons and make the muscles move
the paper states that previous efforts
would target the dorsal column of the
spinal cord but this approach decided to
go to the spinal dorsal roots
the researchers believe that this would
provide better restoration of more
diverse movement in the most severe
cases of spinal injury
so giving the neurons in the muscles an
electrical current is one thing but it
has to be done just right
in fact the system has to simulate the
electrical messages from the brain so
the timing of the signals has to be done
precisely and done in such a way that it
makes the patient's leg muscles contract
in a coordinated manner that resembles a
human step
in the paper they refer to this as a
quote natural activation pattern
as the research paper puts it quote
targeting the individual dorsal roots
with a predefined timing can reproduce
the natural activation pattern of motor
neurons during walking end quote
but how are they going to figure out how
to interface the system with the right
neurons within the body
well it's actually pretty interesting
how they went about it
first the team of scientists took mri
images of 27 spines and then fed that
into an algorithm
the algorithm then produced a predictive
model of the average spinal cord this
included the size and a map of the
layout of neurons
so what was this magic algorithm well
it's a program that already exists and
has for a little while it's called sims
for life
the program could generate finite
element models of the spine generate the
nerve layouts as well as simulate the
voltages and electrical current in the
neurons
amazingly these predictions meant that
they could test the feasibility of their
systems without trying it out on a live
patient it could all be optimized and
evaluated in simulation and i think
that's pretty cool
after some more tweaking and simulation
they came up with the final design
next it was time to install the device
neurosurgeons implanted three men with
the device all of the participants had
their spinal cords completely cut in
separate motorbike accidents and were
completely paralyzed
after 10 days of recovery after surgery
the men started training with the device
and accompanying software
amazingly the simulations beforehand in
the software proved to be accurate
all three participants recovered some
level of movement within just one day of
activating the implant this included
being able to walk on a treadmill while
their weight was supported
one of the patients mikel roccati states
quote the first few steps were
incredible a dream come true
it wasn't only walking though the
participants were also able to do
activities such as peddling a bicycle
and performing squats the device guided
their muscles through all the movements
it should be noted that the patients
aren't fully walking yet
but as reggie edgerton an exercise
physiologist at the university of
california who was also working on
spinal cord injury solutions told nature
quote the next question is whether
stimulation over a long time will help
the motor neurons grow the correct
connections to carry out the movements
without stimulation
end quote
we'll have to wait and see this could be
big if it does come to pass
right now the system has 16 electrodes
but a higher number of electrodes say 32
could provide higher resolution movement
the team plans to move testing into the
united states and has already received
approval from the fda they're going to
test the system in a us-based clinical
trial with more people
the researchers plan to focus on people
with more recent injuries because tests
done in rodents have shown that animals
tend to recover more motion when the
stimulation begins immediately after
their injury
they're also testing a brain implant
which would directly route mental
instructions to the spinal cord
stimulation machinery this device might
restore other functions lost due to
spinal cord injury such as bladder
control
so there's a lot of work being done in
the space as reggie edgerton says the
work will give many people with spinal
cord injuries reason to have a lot of
hope
but there should be some pause
first of all it's still an invasive
spinal surgery which comes with its own
risks though other scientists are
working on another method which uses
electrodes applied to the skin to
activate the spinal neurons externally
it would be cheaper and less risky
as for mikhail roccati he's very happy
with the results so far quote i'm using
it now every day for a couple of hours
at work in my home to do different kinds
of things now it's a part of my daily
life it's good
working is super important but just
stand up
can solve a lot of kind of problems in
the normal life
maybe just to do a simple shower
without crutches i can stand up and do a
shower
with the walker
i'm free i can walk wherever i want
at this moment
okay now i'm working
[Music]
there are so many patients around the
world
who need a treatment to fight against
paralysis
we have reached
the point where we are ready to develop
this treatment this way we are
collaborating with onward medical that
is developing all the technology to turn
this result
into a treatment available throughout
the world
there you have it
we may have just witnessed the first
steps to a mobile life to those with
severe spinal injuries it's great to see
so what do you guys think about this
i'm personally hoping for much more
progress over the coming decade
if you'd like to discuss this in more
detail head on over to the coldfusion
discord
also don't forget to check out my
podcast through the web in the
description
so thanks so much for watching
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh